في كل الاحوال وبعيدا عن مساعي اوكرانيا
فان الجدل حول الصاروخ انتهى نسبيا باعلان
من الرئيس البولندي اندريدو ده
ظهر الرئيس مع رئيسه ليؤكد ان المعلومات
تشير الى ان الصاروخ سوف ياتي الصنع من
طراز اف 300 وان لا دليل على اطلاقه من
روسيا وانه في الاغلب تم اطلاقه من منظومه
دفاعيه اوكرانيه
لا يوجد ما يشير الى ان الضربه الصاروخيه
كانت تستهدف البلاد في عمل متعمد اما رئيس
الوزراء متى يسموراوسكي فسدد على ان بلاده
لم تطلب تفعيل الماده الرابعه من ميثاق
نيته التي تطيح بدء مشاورات فيما اذا كانت
تهديد موجوده وكيفيه مواجهته
لكن الامر لا يحتمل التهاون فاموراوسكي
اوضح ان بلاده ستعزز وجود قواتها وقوات
نيته على الحدود الشرقيات
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا
اطلق الصواريخ لتحديد هذا الهجوم الروسي
تشير تقديرات الى انه تم اسقاط نصف
الصواريخ الروسيه
الاوكرانيه لسوء الحظ من المحتمل جدا ان
يكون احد الصواريخ التي اطلقتها الدفاعات
الجويه الاوكرانيه قد سقط على اراضينا
والارجح انه لم يكن انفجارا للصاروخ نفسه
لكن من المحتمل لانه كان انفجارا للوقود
المتبقي فيه ربما يكون صاروخ اس 300 صنع
في الاتحاد السوفيتي وهو صاروخ قديم ولا
يوجد دليل على انه مطلق من الجانب الروسي
وعقد اجتماع عن طارئا احط بشان الصاروخ
والذي كان الغموض يحيط بمصده وقت الاستماع
بعد الاجتماع ايد الامين العام للحلف ينس
طولكرم برج روايه بولندا واكد انه لا
مؤشرات على ان سقوط الصاروخ كان عملا
هجوميا متعمدا لكن في كل الاحوال ستبقى
روسيا مولاما ولو بشكل غير مباشره بحسب
ستوتنبرج فكثافه صواريخها واستمرار الحرب
الديالك هذا الحديث
انه الجيش
التحقيق في هذا الحديث مستمر ونحن بحاجه
الى انتظار النتائج لكن ليس لدينا ما يشير
الى ان هذا كان نتيجه هجوم متعمد وليس
لدينا ما يشير الى ان روسيا تستعد لعمليات
عسكريه هجوميه ضد الناس تحليلنا الاولي
يشير الى ان الحادثه كان على الارجح بسبب
صاروخ دفاع جوي اوكراني تم اطلاقه للدفاع
عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه ضد هجمات صواريخ
كروز الروسيه لكن قولي ان اوضح هذا ليس
خطا اوكرانيا روسيا تتحمل المسؤوليه
النهائيه لانها تواصل حربها غير القانونيه
ضد اوكرانيا لكن بشكل عام لافتا ان
العواصم الغربيه التي سارعت لابداء الدعم
لبولندا دعت الى التزام الحذر بشان تحديد
مصدر القذيفه حتى ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن منذ البدايه راى انه من غير المحتمل
ان اطلاق الصاروخ الذي اصاب هولندا اطلق
من روسيا
5 5
من الجانب الامريكي بينما ردد الكاملين
بما وصفه بالهستيريا من طرف مسؤولين كبار
لدول عده واعتبر ان تصريحاتهم لم تقم على
بيانات حقيقيه تابعنا ذلك في اخبار عاجله
بالامس في العربيه 360 اذا تذكرون لكن
ماذا عن باقي ردود الفعل الغربيه المانيا
اقترح الدعم بولندا بدوريات جويه بعد سقوط
صاروخ على اراضي الاخيره وقال المتحدث
باسم وزاره الدفاع الالمانيه ان برلين
ستعرض على وارسو تسيير دوريات جويه مع
مقاتلات يورو فايتر الالمانيه
فقد دعت على لسانها الى تدعيم الجبهه
الشرقيه
بمنظومات الدفاع جويه للتصدي لروسيا
[موسيقى]
ليتوانيا ستدعم وستشارك في المناقشات
وسنتحدث عن نشر منظومات الدفاع الجوي على
الحدود البولنديه الاوكرانيه وكل الجناح
الشرقي للنيتو اذكركم انه خلال قمه الناتو
في مدريد قبل بضعه اشهر توصلنا لاهميه نشر
المنظومه في الجناح الشرقيه للحلو»
والحادث الذي شاهدناه في بولندا يجعلنا
نفكر في كيفيه تنفيذ ذلك بسرعه البيانات
لن تنفع التنفيذ سيساعدنا على الدفاع عن
انفسنا
لكن حتى انتفاد الناتو الانزلاق نحو الرد
المباشر هذه المره فما هي الظروف التي قد
تدفعه لذلك في المستقبل
السيناريو الابرز هو هجوم روسيا على دوله
عضو بالنيتو بشكل مباشره اي ان يتكرر حادث
الامس ولكن بشكل متعمد من روسيا سواء ضد
بولندا او ضد دول اخرى في نيته احتمال اخر
هو اذا استهدفت روسيا قافله امداد عسكريه
غربيه لدى عبورها من احدى دول الناتو
حينها ايضا يتم تفعيل الماده الخامسه من
ميثاق النيدو المتعلقه بالدفاع المشترك
سيناريو اخير هو ان يؤدي القتال الى وقوع
انفجار في منشاه صناعيه مع اطلاق غازات
كيميائيه سامه تؤثر مثلا على اوكرانيا او
تصل باثارها الى النت الى دول النيته يبدو
هذا الاحتمال الاضعف لكنه يظل قائما
[موسيقى]